Could you discuss what you learned about the L salivarius protocol? My carapter thinks it can cure cancer as
He had a spot on his cheek and he took four caps a day and
It ate a hole in his cheek. He wants me to take nine caps a day
But since I'm seen flesh being eaten away. I decided to stop it. I mentioned it last week. Yes
So it's really interesting
When once I looked it up. I realized. Oh, yeah, I did look at this before
It is a lactobacillus
protocol probiotic
microbiota and
It shows really a lot of promise in cancer. So I
Would be careful to say anything can cure cancer, but the truth is lots of things can and
Would it cure everybody's cancer? Of course, nothing will cure everybody's cancer, but I
Don't think there's any harm in taking it. So there's multiple
peer-reviewed studies on it
Quite interesting. I'm actually going to write a blog about it
But you know the tweet for my blog. I don't think there's anything wrong with taking it and the product that you sent me
Only showed what was it two billion units of
the
Salamarius
In that probiotic
That's not even a high dose. So I don't see anything wrong with you taking it. You can certainly
If he muscle tested you on that nine caps
There's nothing wrong with you tight trading up to that and if it is causing
Like it eating away. It's not gonna eat away healthy tissue. So it would only eat
unhealthy tissue
So I don't think there's any trouble wrong with taking it now. I'll tell you there's I just talked to somebody today about another
protocol that I've used on people
Whether it's whether it's cancer related or not or not
Years and years ago cautious was back in the 90s
I had a patient that came to see me. This is what actually what is practicing down in Texas
When we were doing missionary work and he had a hole in the bottom of his foot and you could see his bone
And this was going on for about a year and he could not get better
He'd been to every world specialists taken antibiotic creams and ointments all this stuff
And I was practicing with the friend to mind who also did kinesiology
He was older than me and he actually gave me the idea test him for a probiotic
So we tested him for a probiotic and can't remember what probiotic and it was irrelevant and all he did is
Open up the capsule of probiotic and sprinkle it in the wound and it healed up completely in two weeks
So it was amazing since that time it was a long time ago. I did I've done that little protocol on wounds that would
Inheal sprinkling a probiotic in it and it was not a specific probiotic. So this is a specific probiotic
That this person is talking about here that in this question that was has been shown to help kill cancer cells
And it's been proven that it does do that but there's like hundreds and hundreds of
of
Published reports published studies on
Curcumin and Burberry and all all the supplements that we talk about on a daily basis in our office. There's
hundreds of published reports
Proving that they have they have curative
Properties for cancer. So it's not uncommon that you know a probiotic of this
Magnitude would do the same thing
So I don't think there's anything wrong with taking it
And I don't think there's anything wrong with if you have an open wound sprinkle some it directly into the open wound
And I don't think there's anything wrong with it eating away and created open wound. That's exactly what happens when we treat
Well, when we treat melanova with black salm it literally creates a crater
I mean literally looks like a wound crater on your skin because it literally eats away the cancer and the cancer comes out
And and then you the you have to you know the throw away the little piece of cancer that came out of the skin
And we've seen miraculous things with that too, but it doesn't necessarily look good when it when it leaves this crater
But it does heal up and it will heal with a scar but better not to have the cancer so
I think it's a great thing. I think you should go back on it. I wouldn't be afraid of it